the witching hour is here folks the
season 1 finale of the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina has arrived
and there's a lot to unpack in this
video I'll be going over a brief recap
of the finale and then diving right into
the ending and tackling some of your
unanswered questions so if you'd like to
skip right to the ending explained I've
left a link in the description that will
take you right there but you're gonna
want to stick around because I've got
some theories I haven't seen thrown
around so without further ado gather
round and prepare to get spooked because
the finale has come and this one's lit
episode 10 begins in miss Ward wells
home as she tells someone we can't see a
story about Sabrina almost as if
everything we've watched this season has
been a retelling of Ward wells from this
night Ward well starts by saying she's
surprised no one predicted the events of
the night of the storm the signs were
there ill omens including Harvey pouring
ink onto a drawing of him his brother
and his mom funny how the blackness only
covers Tommy considering the events of
episode 8 Roz begins to embrace her
cunning and confronts Sabrina about her
witness but after Sabrina explains
everything the group embraces Sabrina's
not the witch they'll have to be worried
about
since Sabrina's friends have rallied
around her instead of condemning her
which would ward Wilmes for Sabrina to
make a tough choice what is the price
she's willing to pay to save her mortal
friends Wardwell kills a virgin and
summons the Greendale 13 the hung
witches of old Greendale they have one
hour at midnight for two nights to wreak
havoc and get revenge on the town and
these witches ain't messing around as
Dorothy explains to Susie these women
were brutally killed no one would dare
touch them or bury them except Dorothea
they're not just out for mortals but
witches too in the woods Ambrose and
Luke spot the 13 performing a ritual the
witches provide them with a warning to
relay back to the coven they are
summoning the red angel of death the
Crimson Avenger who will take away every
firstborn child in Greendale be they
mortal or witch the coven decides to
hide away in the Academy United they
will have enough power to place a
protection spell around them which
leaves the mortals all alone ready for
slaughter sake you to try and save the
sitting ducks of Greendale the Spellman
summon a storm in order to herd the
mortals in
one location the town's designated
shelter Baxter hi there like the witches
at the Academy the four can unite to
cast a protection spell on everyone at
once but Zelda gets pulled away lady
Blackwood is in labor then Ambrose gets
pulled away this time by Luke who
doesn't want to risk Ambrose dying he
loves him no no stop I still don't trust
you Luke with just Sabrina and Hilda
there's not enough power to protect the
school in comes Wardwell with a plan
there's one way Sabrina could gain
enough power to stop this once and for
all
sign the book of the Beast what will it
be Sabrina keep your freedom or save
your friends and so she signs with this
newfound power the Dark Lord tells her
exactly what she needs to do to save the
town in fact he already told her in her
vision from the malum malice in Episode
one burned them the witch's taunt
Sabrina only Hellfire can destroy them
and there have only been three witches
in history powerful enough to summon it
and for now there are five Sabrina's
hair turns all platinum the same color
is in the comics the town is saved but a
lot has happened Zelda delivers
faustus's son who consumed his weaker
brother in the womb similar to nightmare
Hawthorn in Episode five will later
learn that the twin is alive and a girl
born before the boy something seemingly
shameful in the eyes of Blackwood and
perhaps the witches so Zelda hides the
baby away in order to protect her
fearing what Blackwood might do he'll
though on the other hand has a new love
with something to hide of his own
Ambrose finds himself getting in the
wrong crowd and Sabrina says a final
goodbye to Harvey a classic I'm staying
a way to protect you kind of thing and
finally we get a look at who Ward Wells
been speaking to its Hawthorne seems
like he finally got that drink with her
ward well then reveals herself as lilith
satan's concubine and first wife to Adam
she's grooming Sabrina to take her place
as mother of demons and Satan's foot
soldier once she does Satan will reward
her and make her his wife queen of hell
and then remember what I said back in
episode 3 how Wardwell feasts on male
flesh
stole ascension the Dark Lord might want
Sabrina for a bride instead of her gets
a swift snap of the neck if Sabrina gets
in her way she'll deal with her in a
similar fashion this season finishes on
the new Sabrina walking all Kill Bill
style with the Weird Sisters now a
full-fledged witch is she evil now is
she friends with the weird sisters or is
she just playing along so let's get into
the real meat and bones of the video
there are a ton of questions still to be
answered but I'll start with this what
was the whole point of the season what
was the big moment every episode was
leading up to this the signing of the
book of the beast
throughout the season Wardwell on
Blackwood under the guidance of the Dark
Lord take a number of steps to try and
push Sabrina towards the path of night
it starts with simple lies Blackwood
tells her about what the signing means
that she'll have complete freedom but
that doesn't work and she runs away from
her baptism then it's the trial which
was a means to get Sabrina attending the
Academy of unseen Arts there she'll meet
cool new magical friends like Nick and
learn about the power of witch hood all
will under the eyes of Faustus surely
she'll want to go full witch then but
they learn Sabrina's connection with
their mortal friends is too strong and
decided needs to be severed Wardwell
reveals Harvey's family history as witch
killers but that doesn't work
she then corrupts Sabrina to the point
of necromancy which does work kinda in
messing up her relationship with Harvey
but Roz and Susie hold strong even after
learning she's a witch
so Wardwell reverses her plan rather
than sever Sabrina's tied to the mortals
she'll use it against her and forces
Sabrina to make a sacrifice her
signature for the lives of the mortals
and that Sabrina's biggest strength and
biggest weakness her love for others the
whole season has led to this moment what
the Dark Lord wants Sabrina's name in
the book of the beast so why why is it
so important for the Dark Lord to get
her specifically Sabrina's signature in
all likelihood it's because Stoll is's
take is true he wants her as his queen
but again why her we learn in episode 3
that Sabrina's dad offered her name to
the book of the Beast in order to gain
permission to marry immortal
Diana Spellman which means the soul of
Sabrina is rightfully the Dark Lord's at
least as far as he's concerned perhaps
he had Sabrina pegged from the start to
be his wife perhaps having a half mortal
has benefits we don't
know about but when Sabrina refuses her
dark baptism the Dark Lord in turn has
been refused his rightful soul and the
Dark Lord means to collect thus all the
trouble which leads me to my next
question is Sabrina a twin before her
dark baptism Sabrina gets a vision of
two babies one with cloven feet I
initially thought this might be symbolic
of Sabrina's choice to either follow the
path of night or light but Zelda's
storyline of stealing away the
Blackwood's firstborn girl makes me
think otherwise like perhaps they did it
sixteen years ago with Sabrina
especially after this line we can raise
her we've died before and in limbo
Sabrina's mom says they took my baby
after the baptism they told me she had
died just like Blackwood was told his
other twin had died so if this baby
isn't Sabrina it must be a twin right
hell perhaps she's referring to Sabrina
as the one they took away one good twin
one evil we should also note that in
Melissa Joan Hart Sabrina the Teenage
Witch she too had an evil twin
so where is Sabrina's twin at this point
all we have is speculation there's a lot
of strange holes to fill in with
Sabrina's past just like our next
question what happened to Edward and
Diana Spellman this is a question I've
rarely heard talked about online and I
have a few thoughts about it most of the
witch world believes Edward and Diana
Spellman were killed in an accident a
plane crash but we all know this story
is bull so what happened in episode 1
Zelda and Hilda say Sabrina's parents
were flying to Italy when their plane
crashed what's so special about Italy
the holy city of the Vatican the place
Ambrose tried to blow up a high priest
of the night going to meet say the Pope
remember the high priest of night is
considered the Pope of the Dark Lord
there's a connection there this meeting
probably rubbed a few witches the wrong
way and maybe they were bringing a
special baby with them as well a baby
both mortal and witch something that you
can night the two sides could this have
been Edward Spellman's true goal again
we'll have to wait and see also remember
back in episode 1 when Sabrina has the
vision of the two babies and her parents
they carry luggage with them almost as
if on the run so those were three major
questions I had after the finale but
what about some of the other smaller
mysteries yet to be solved like who or
what is dr. Cerberus
the end of episode 10 Hilda finally
finds love and dr. C but as he walks
away something ain't right with him so
what kind of creature is he first off
not a vampire he's often seen in a
Dracula
esque outfit but during his interview
with Hilda it's broad daylight
so hey could be that vampires in this
universe walk the day I'm still looking
at you Luke wait are you serious yes yes
I am
could he be some kind of demon possibly
but my belief is that his true nature
lies in his name Cerberus Cerberus aka
the Hound of Hades and what could be
more hound like than a werewolf next how
did Nana Walker die at the beginning of
the episode Wardwell describes that
Roz's Nana knew she was going to die
that night
knitting her own death shroud then at
the end of the episode it seems as
though Sabrina saved the day before the
red angel of death could get anyone
nonetheless Nana passes on so what
happened was it just good old-fashioned
old age or did the angel actually get to
her this is one we might have to wait
until next season to get a definitive
answer on but my guess is that it has
something to do with passing on the
cunning to Raw's Nana has fulfilled her
duty now it's with her granddaughter
notice the strange inward breath she
takes as Nana's spirit leaves the room
who killed Connor remember Connor the
Warlock killed by a witch hunter back in
episode 1 he seemed like a major plot
point early on in the season but is
rarely talked about after episode 2 all
I know
Luke is somehow involved how careless he
was about his ex-boyfriend at the
funeral
how Connors familiar the Iguana dies as
soon as Luke gets involved and Connors
parents only spoke about those occult
items he owned possible clues in his
death to Ambrose and Hilda something
Ambrose likely would have told Luke
about I don't trust you and I never will
let's not forget that Luke is still
under a love spell that Hilda gave him
at the end of episode six when Luke
teleports ambers during the storm and
tells him he loves him is very possible
he still just under that spell something
that will undoubtedly come into play
next season poor Ambrose why doesn't
Sabrina have a witch's mark we do know
after episode three that kinky kinkle
try saying that three times fast tell
Sabrina she doesn't have a witch's mark
the simplest explanation is that it's
because sabrina is half mortal and not
full witch and finally why doesn't Salem
speak
No one of the big disappointments for
Sabrina fans this season was that Salem
never spoke in truth it seems like he
has been speaking like in this scene
where Sabrina explains her plan to trick
bad ABAT it's just we the audience
haven't heard him yet
well excluding his very early appearance
in Episode one before he turns into a
cat but that's all changed now that
we've heard stola speak expect to hear
more from Salem next season literally
that wraps up my ending explained in
episode 10 breakdown I've had a lot of
fun diving into the world of Greendale
and the Church of night with you if you
have any more unanswered questions or
theories of your own feel free to
comment down below and luckily we won't
have too long to wait until next video
they're releasing a Christmas special
December 14th that's sure to be chilling
ok that was terrible stop until then
keep walking that path of night